dick Stockton joining us now dick how
are you this morning you know I'm really
good Dan it's a great to be on with you
and uh it seems like only yesterday and
he scored a 63 it's only 30 years ago
what do you remember about that day well
uh you know what a lot of people don't
remember perhaps is that number one of
the Bulls but only 30 games uh the
Jordan you know mr. you know 64 game for
the broken ankle broken foot yep uh they
didn't want him to play many many
minutes or even jeopardize his career by
going on the celtics were the dominant
team may be one of the greatest of all
time and the Celtics were in the process
of sweeping the Bulls the Bulls really
had no chance in the series I mean they
can have you know a lot of the great
supporting players that he had later you
know they had eight cores even Orlando
Woolridge they were good players but not
the kind of players like Scottie Pippen
were so it wasn't all those others and
so uh you know the Celtics were also
unimpressed with Jordan he didn't play
that much that year it was a second year
and they said who is this guy anyway hmm
well you did have sort of that phantom
call at the end of regulation where they
called Kevin McHale a foul on Jordan
attempting a three and then he hits
three free throws to go into overtime
but was there a moment where you started
to sense you see in something that you
hadn't seen before yes uh dannon and I
was watching show earlier I think it was
the most important game that Jordan had
played going into it but it was building
and the the way he was able to weave his
way for short jumpers against the you
know that big front line the Celtics had
and the way he was able to bank in shots
he look like a man on a mission and he
was the best obviously the best player
on this team and the team wasn't going
to do much in fact they lost the game I
mean a lot of people with well Jordan
scored 63 and they won the game but I
think that he opened the eyes of the
Celtics in that game when it was over uh
you know Larry Bird said do you know we
just saw God disguise Michael Jordan
I do think that that was
transformational for the rest of the NBA
maybe not Jordan but in the eyes of
everybody else where you're trying to
get the respect of you know the Lakers
with magic you had the Pistons like
Jordan wanted to say hey include me in
with the big big names and I think that
that was sort of a coming out party for
him no question about it dan I mean
here's a team that won 30 games I mean
they were 37 games worse than the
Celtics and it's a one against eight you
know they make the playoffs one of the
worst teams record-wise ever to get into
postseason and and now he's playing
against this tremendous team and it's
not the Bulls we remember later on you
know it'd be several more years before
they were able to really reach to what
they you know Chief during the time of
the the Bulls domination and and when he
scored 263 I think really raised you
know another level the interest of the
NBA I mean we started with you know the
doctor and then we went to Jordan and
bird and bird was their births court by
the way 36 points in that game yeah and
here's the guy who plays 53 minutes of
this double double overtime game and I
think that was one of the stamps that
made the NBA make the big jump you also
called Jordan hit the jumper over poor
Craig Ehlo in the Cleveland Cavaliers
when everybody in the building thought
you double team Jordan that's the the
only guy on the floor who can beat you
and they somehow let him beat them what
do you remember about that play that
call but well I remember that it went
down to the wire in fact yellow hit a
big shot yellow you know went back and
forth and the Cavaliers were a dominant
team yes and I think that they beat him
five times during the regular season or
an Ohio guy right you're probably
rooting for the cab that was a great
Cavaliers team one of the great teams to
never win a title you're right and uh
and any gets that shot and I think the
greatest thing about that shot was the
way he jumped like forever four or five
feet in the air and pumped his fist the
first of many we would see and that was
a huge victory and I think we we kind of
knew that this was the kind of guy that
would deliver in in in situations like
that I mean we know you know again
you know in the NBA Finals when he fed
the steeper the open man but you know
getting back to that boston game I mean
everyone guarded George in that game
bird every name a guy they they were on
him and they couldn't stop them and you
would think that a team of that ilk at
the time you know playing on the parquet
floor would manage to you know they
trapped him all over the place and the
63 that's what makes it great is that he
was really the only threat you also
called the Carlton Fisk Game six
nineteen seventy five World Series the
if it stays fair so many great moments
become greater moments because the the
person who's calling the action it's
it's it's natural it's honest Al
Michaels saying do you believe in
miracles you mean it just captured the
moment it didn't overshadow the moment
it complimented the moment if it stays
fair is it sounds simple but in the
moment to say it and sort of let Carlton
Fisk action which need no words I
thought was the brilliant part of that
if it stays fair and you saw Fisk and I
I did there's a talent a knack of
staying out of the way and you certainly
did it well you know thank you for that
day and I mean it was no other way and
as I've said too many many times you
know you can call a drive hit to deep
left center field you know it could be
out of these days you know way back way
back you know and all that stuff read
Barbara's call on you know the GM frito
catch in the 47 World Series but this
wasn't one of them this was a line shot
and you couldn't give it any you know
poletik kind of call you had to say what
was your instinct that moment and i
think that's what how did you know in
that miracle on ice it was his instinct
that took over and and you can't plan
these things and if you do it sounds
like you did and uh you know so it was
just instinctive and you know and then
let the moment take it so that you know
call i mean the crowds yelling what
beats the pictures and the sounds you
know then John Kylie playing the organ
Izzy circled the bases and you know it's
just a natural thing and you just have
to be blessed that you happen to be
there at the right time at that moment
to be able to make a
all like that in a game like do you have
any sports memorabilia you've collected
over the years with games you've done
well I do and you know I have uh D
soccer.com which is my website and I
have a lot of the highlights that I have
done I mean I have not collected jerseys
uh or speakers from players or any of
those things up but but to me you know i
do remember the calls of plays that I
that I've been part of and and I have a
lot of that and there's a lot of things
that that I remembered a lot of areas
you know and pictures that are in my
office that are a really memorable
pictures uh you know with Michael Jordan
and I uh actually you know holding a
cigar in in the locker room many many
years ago uh but I have a lot of those
photos and not the memories are a great
near there and you know the one thing
that is interesting about the jordan
thing and i thought of this when when i
got the call from Todd about you know
being on is that you know everyone
thinks the Bulls won the game that day
and they didn't the celtics won and it's
similar to the 75 World Series yeah
whenever I run into Johnny Bench and he
says to me dick just remember who won
the world series 75 and and and dan I
tell him wasn't that the series that was
called off after six games they decided
to just make it even well you also that
competition between bench and Fisk as to
who was the best catcher and Thurman
Munson was also in there as well so i
could imagine bench still being a little
competitive there with Carlton Fisk yes
they did win yes they did that a dick
great talk to you thanks for joining us
pipe sound great and uh good luck thank
you Dan good to be on with you to
remember that the three decades ago
arguably dick Stockton d Stockton calm
for his website there the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
you